[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
would you like to hear an amazing fact
friends spiders are known for making
some of the strongest fibers in the
world spider silk in general is widely
regarded as the strongest natural fabric
known and it's at least as half as
strong as steel thread of the same
thickness and much more elastic in fact
when you consider its weight spider silk
is actually five times as strong as
steel pound-for-pound more specifically
scientists have found the toughest
material on earth made by a living
creature is the silk produced by the
Darwin's bark spider after testing its
tensile strength they discovered it was
more than twice as tough as any other
spider silk and more than ten times
stronger than Kevlar you might be
surprised to learn they're now some
companies making super-strong clothing
from synthetic spider silk even more
bulletproof than that or Kevlar is the
protective clothing spoken of in the
Bible stay with us friends we're going
to learn more as we bring you this
edition of a Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
that's one eight hundred four sixty
three seventy to ninety seven now let's
join our host pastor Doug Batchelor
welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live and this is a live
international interactive Bible study
and we invite you to participate we have
phone lines wide open if you have a
Bible question give us a call here's the
phone number 800 four six three seven
two nine seven eight hundred God says
you ready one more time eight hundred
four six three seven two 97 call us with
your Bible questions and you've got an
excellent chance of getting your
question on tonight's program my name is
Doug Batchelor and my regular co-host
pastor John Ross is on vacation tonight
and so with God's help we're gonna move
forward but let's ask him now father in
heaven we thank you so much for your
blessings especially this time of year
when we think of all we have to be
grateful for and we thank you for the
Word of God Lord that changes hearts
these words who are indeed spirit and
they are life be with this program Lord
pray that the word goes forth that
hearts are touched and that you are
glorified in Jesus name Amen
you know I'm always fascinated with
creatures I was talking to a friend I
did a TV program where I was holding a
snake and she told me today that kind of
wigged her out but I was always amazed
by snakes and spiders maybe a typical
boy I remember being with Karen in
beliefs and we went to a zoo there and
they let you hold a great big tarantula
and I thought that was a coolest thing
in the world because it almost looked
like you know puppy dog you could talk
to a creepy puppy dog but they're big
and so I've been fascinated by spiders
and just how God designed them where
they're spinnerets were able to produce
silk different kinds of silk for
different functions from one spider as
some is more rigid some
as quickly some is elastic and it seems
like man is always trying to copy the
design of God when the Air Force wanted
to understand better gliding planes they
started looking at the albatross and
looking at the seagull and and when they
were designing their Jets they looked at
the the back angling wings of the Swift
and
I've heard that they studied the head of
the woodpecker when they were trying to
design football helmets that wouldn't
allow you to get brain damage well we
knew that they'd be looking at the
strength of the spider silk and several
companies have been launched with
millions of dollars backing them to try
to produce an artificial spider silk
because it is the strongest substance in
the natural world that's biologically
produced and
yep they've they've already got some
companies that are making jackets and
closeout of this artificial or synthetic
spider silk that's supposed to be even
stronger than Kevlar but if you can
think of a thousands of uses for it I'm
sure fishermen would love to have
fishing line ten times stronger and a
lot of people could find very
interesting practical uses I read one
time that the orb spider in New Guinea
that there are some spiders their webs
are so strong that the natives there and
Papua New Guinea use them as hand
fishing nets and they can hold a fish
you know the Bible tells us that there
is a fabric there is a clothing there's
an armor a Kevlar that God makes for you
to keep us safe from the enemy you read
about this in the book of Ephesians
chapter 6 verse 13 it says wherefore
take unto you the whole armour of God
that you might be able to stand in the
evil day having done all to stand stand
therefore having girded your loins with
truth and having the breastplate of
righteousness and your feet shod with
the preparation of the gospel and above
all taking the shield of faith wherewith
you're able to quench all the fiery
darts of the wicked one and the helmet
of salvation in the or to the spirit
that is the Word of God Paul describes
there in Ephesians 6 the armour of God
that we put on to protect us in our
daily battles with the enemy and it
it's the supernatural power that God
gives you in his word to resist
temptation that's what Jesus used every
time he was tempted he quoted scripture
the promises of God to the devil he said
it is written it is written is written
every time he was tempted and we'd like
you to know how to put on that armor of
God friends do you struggle with
temptation do you find sometimes you're
easily overcome are you falling in the
same area again and again and you would
like to be free from your misguided
thoughts and bad habits learn about the
armor of God we will send you a free
book and it's not just a a metaphor it's
it's something real that you can do and
get some practical tips in this book an
easy reading called the armor of God and
the price is great it's called free
here's the number for the free resource
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven oh we're giving you two
numbers so be careful not to get it
mixed up the number for the free
resource the armor of God just call and
ask for it nobody's gonna harass you or
bother you it's a gift and it'll bless
you eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven we only ask if you do
call and we send you the book please
read it and then share it with somebody
now if you have a question we do have
several lines open I think people are
out traveling for Thanksgiving right now
but if you want to call in your Bible
question we've got a lot of friends and
truckers listening on satellite radio
you have a Bible question don't claim to
have all the answers but I'll share what
I've learned in the last 40 years number
is 800 God says here it is in regular
numbers 800 for six three seven 297 800
for six
372 9 seven will bring your question
into our studio headquarters and with
that we're gonna go to our first caller
who is Ken calling from Arkansas
listening on the internet ken welcome to
the program
how're you doing today do well how are
you like I've got a question I want to
know what what the Bible says about
changing your mind once you say
something you give a verbal
promise not promise or to someone here's
the scenario
I have rental property and I told
someone they could have the property for
such-and-such price I've got so many
phone calls I decided to go up $25 the
lady refused and I didn't let her have
it so what does the Bible say about that
changing your mind you know well making
a green baby yeah it tells us in the
book of Proverbs that will further the
Bible's is better not to valve into vow
and not to keep it yeah
yeah well you know and it may not be too
late but if you
and then you'll read in Psalms and I'm
trying to remember it maybe um Psalms 15
where it says yeah I think it is some 15
we're a believer will swear to his own
hurt but he does not change in other
words you make a valve and you and you
realize wow I'm gonna lose money on this
deal but I've you know I made a promise
I have to keep it proverbs 7:14 today I
have paid my vows and
so yeah you've got when you make a vow
to God do not delay to pay it that's
Ecclesiastes 5 4 says actually tune it
two ways it says pay what you have vowed
please yesyes 5:5 better not to vowel
tune to vow and not to pay and Jesus
said let your yea be a in your Navy nay
now somebody called me once and they
said well when I was lost I sold my soul
to the devil do I need to keep that
promise and I said no please don't
you know because yeah that's a one-way
road it doesn't end well and
you know the devil is a liar but you
know if you if you advertise something
for a certain price and then someone
says I'll take it you can't really
change the price on them later if you
post it at a certain price and then you
reconsider before you promise it to
anybody well then you know you've got
the freedom to raise the price or lower
the price but if someone has agreed to
what you promised you need to stick to
your word I got you yeah that makes
sense yeah thank you so much bad alright
Ken here we appreciate your call and
I've actually got a sermon that deals
with what is truth and I talked a little
bit there about vows you can listen to
that at the amazing facts website which
is simply amazing facts dot o-r-g and
appreciate Ken's call that does free up
another line and so if you got a phone
call Bible question rather here's the
phone number eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven eight hundred
four six three seven two nine seven
several lines open we've just got two
operators helping to screen the call so
if it rings just let it ring for a
minute I'm gonna talk next to AJ who's
calling from El Cajon California AJ
you're on the air with Bible answers
live hey are you doing pastor thank you
for taking my call yeah um so my
question and I'll ask it and then I'll
hang up and go ahead and that you answer
in the Bible there's a lot of
as a management how the idea of the
Bride of Christ and you know Christ as a
lover of my soul which I get that but
you know there are songs that are more
in the feminine and I kind of understand
the idea but I'm looking more for like
as men how do we
reconcile that I'll hang up and I'll go
ahead and listen to your answer alright
hey thank you very much AG I'll do my
best
the love of God in the Bible you can't
really make it gender exclusive for men
or women sometimes God compares his love
to the love of a mother he talks about a
mother hen guarding her chicks and he
compares it to his love he says can a
woman forget her nursing child they may
forget but I will not forget you and
even the name God Almighty in the Bible
is read I think it's more literally
translated than many breasted one
meaning the one who can provide nurse
for her children
so sometimes God figures his love that
way and then you know it this also says
husband's and this isn't Ephesians
husbands love your wives as Christ loves
the church so you've got the male model
God of course is called our Father in
heaven and that God the Father so loved
the world he gave His Son again there
you've got two more masculine ideas but
in when we think about our love for
Jesus
and I realized that
the love we would have is something like
the love of David and Jonathan there
were two men that had a pure love that
was not at all sensual in the Bible they
just loved who the other person was and
you know in our our society today it's
sort of saturated with sex when you talk
about love our deep love people
automatically try to include the sexual
dimension of that but biblically the
greatest love is is a love that is free
from that and in heaven it says they'll
neither marry nor given in marriage and
we'll just be overflowing with love for
God so yes sometimes it's pictured as
God loves us as his bride but there's
there's really no conflict with the idea
that the love of God sometimes it
appears as the love of a woman or a
mother sometimes it's the level of a man
so we can all relate thank you very much
for your call AJ gonna talk next to Tony
Tony is calling listening on now
satellite radio from is that do-boy
Pennsylvania
yes yeah welcome to the program
thank you my question
to you refers to the book of Enoch you
know yes and and and if you refers to it
do you think you should have been
included in the scriptures and and other
books too like like like a second Ezra
or the Maccabees do something like that
you know miracles involved in the book
and they wonder if there's some books
missing from the Bible yeah
they
miss some of them that they should air
alright well let me talk about that for
just a minute it is true Jude quotes
from a book called The Book of Enoch
most of the scholars doubt that this was
a book written by Enoch and then it
would have been taken on the ark by Noah
Kadena clip before the flood and somehow
was passed down from Noah to
you know Lamech and Terra and Abraham
and on so forth
most believed that the Book of Enoch is
a book that was written during the
Jewish captivity in Babylon that's the
first time it really appears it does
still exist today Jude does quote from
the book he's not endorsing the whole
book he's endorsing a line in the book
that talks about the Lord coming and it
is possible that you could read a book
that has some inspired lines in it I
think Martin Luther said some things
that were inspired of God like when he
said here I stand God helped me during
the diet of worms that was an inspired
statement but then Martin Luther he was
a little anima anti-semitic and he would
say some things about Jews that I don't
think were inspired a Paul refers to
even some Greek poets and you can read
about this in acts 17:28 and Paul is
quoting some of the Greek poets well it
doesn't mean those poets all of their
poetry was inspired and needed to be
part of the Bible but there may have
been some inspired lines in the poetry
the book pilgrims progress had some
wonderful inspiring statements in there
written by John Bunyan and even in the
Bible it talks about the books of God
the seer in the Book of Jeff a--the
what God chose to preserve in the Bible
the Canon that we have now is a hundred
percent inspired some of the authors
quote from
inspired selections outside the Bible
but it doesn't mean everything in that
book or everything those authors said
was inspired so I don't know does that
make sense yeah
they were put together by men you know I
didn't and mistaken leaving something
out or you know something like that
yeah I you know I think that the Bible
was not put together really by men I
believe that a supernatural Providence
and a guiding hand
directed the people because it does say
God spoke through holy men who were
inspired by the Holy Spirit I think God
guided those men to assemble the
unquestioned books that were authentic
it doesn't mean that there's nothing
else in the world that God has spoken
through I think that you know there's a
lot of times that God may inspire a
person with a line there with a passage
with a book doesn't mean it becomes part
of the sacred canon so but God did
something supernatural to preserve the
Bible and what we call the sacred
scriptures and as they said the Bible is
an anvil that has worn out many hammers
you know I do have something that deals
with that Tony I'll be happy to send you
a free copy it's the amazing fact study
guide called is there anything left you
can trust you call the resource number
here's that number 880 three five six
seven four seven and tell them you'd
like that study guide on the Bible
called is there anything left you can
trust and we'll be happy to send that to
you appreciate your call and with that
we're gonna go and talk to Tom who is
calling from canyonville Oregon I've
been there before welcome Tom you're on
the air with Bible answers live
yeah well I had a question for you as I
was I get quite a few used by different
pastors on my on the radio that I think
they're from Maryland from Atlanta but
they seem to think that
after you die and
all but when you go to hell you're
incinerated that way I kinda go back to
where you were before you were born
now Tom do you know John 3:16 for
God so loved the world that He gave His
one son keep doing that but whoever to
believe in him should
everlasting life and not perish right
okay not perish but having you're close
enough not perish but have everlasting
life so we're we're faced with two
options right believe never lasting life
not believe perish
the Bible tells us that Jesus came and
died to take our penalty the penalty for
sin Paul says the wages of sin is what
death it doesn't say the wages for sin
is eternal torment for Brazilians of
years unending in flames now i believe
the bible does teach there's a lake of
fire that wicked are cast into the lake
of fire and jesus says every man is
punished according to what he deserves
but then you read in Malachi the days
coming that all the wicked will be
burned up it'll leave them neither root
nor branch
see in the very beginning God told Adam
in the day you sin thereof you'll die
and
the penalty for sin is death and so the
devil though has taken some you know
medieval teachings that people have an
immortal soul and I ask pastors all the
time show me the verse Bible is a big
book it must be there somewhere show me
the verse that says we have an immortal
soul and it's not there but there is a
verse that says God and God only has
immortality not believe Jesus is
immortal and there may be unfallen
angels that are immortal but meaning the
people on this earth we don't have
immortality immortality is given when
Christ comes it says when Jesus comes
then this mortal will put on immortality
God you know of course our bodies get
old and die now we all know that so
immortality is a gift to those who
believe the wicked will be raised and
they will be judged and the Bible says
in Revelation 20 they are cast into the
lake of fire and it says this is the
second death it's the death from which
there is no resurrection
everyone is punished according to what
they deserve sorry had Luke chapter 16
and with the rich man and Lazarus
died you know and the rich man wakes up
Internet well I'm why'd you mention that
let's talk about it for a moment in the
parable and this is my point is it's a
parable only mentioned in the Gospel of
Luke and
he talks about this man a rich man he
doesn't care much about me feasts every
day and then this poor beggar named
Lazarus is at his gate who just is
starving and the dogs lick his sores and
they both die except there's a great
reversal Lazarus who kind of represents
the Gentiles he's in Abraham's bosom
where every Jew wanted to be and the
rich man who is a symbol for the Jewish
nation that had the treasure of truth
they were feasting on he is suddenly in
the Greek place of torment so Jesus is
using
some irony here he's got this that the
poor Gentiles who are starving for the
crumbs of truth there in Abraham's bosom
which is a metaphor for the saved of the
Jews and
the rich Jewish man who didn't share the
gospel with the hungry he's suddenly in
the Greek place of torment which is
called Hades that's the word that's used
and it's clearly a parable because I
mean the Greek the the rich man is
talking to Abraham and I don't think
anyone believes that the people in
heaven are gonna be able to talk to the
people burning in hell that'd be
terrible and furthermore he says you
know you send him with one drop of water
to cool my tongue do we really believe
everybody that dies goes to Abraham's
bosom or is that a symbol so this is a
parable and he's talking about really it
has nothing to do with the state of man
and death it's talking about if we don't
share the truth with those who are
hungry for the crumbs that fall from our
table we may discover in the judgments
there in the place of salvation and
we're on the outside okay but then I was
talking about this with a truckstop
chaplain here not too long ago and he
said it is not a parable because every
other terrible in the Bible
it precedes it this is a parabola on
this particular occasion in it doesn't
that that isn't that doesn't precede the
story that Jesus isn't telling and all
the other parables nobody has named but
in this particular parable Lazarus is
that he said this is not able yeah that
point made before and I would just
respectfully disagree Lazarus was as
common a name as you could have in in
the Greek countries back then it was the
equivalent of John and so I've told many
illustrations where I say little Johnny
told his mother you know and so it's not
uncommon to
take a general name like that it was a
very common name there's several
Lazarus's in the bible but you know can
please let me send you something Tom I
hope you'll let me do it there is a
study guide I'd like to send you it's
got all the scriptures on it and it's
called the rich man and Lazarus and
it'll explain that parable it'll explain
what the Bible teaches about that what
I'm teaching is not anything new this is
what Christians used to believe before
there's sort of this medieval concept
that the soul is gonna burn for ever and
ever and ever and ever you just think
about that think about some teenager who
dies lost he's only lived 13 years but
he dies beyond the age of accountability
and
he's gonna burn as long as Adolf Hitler
in some cases longer I mean the way that
they it's taught it just and yeah I mean
can we comprehend eternity a person
writhing in flames a billion zillion
years go by and no relief and they've
only begun for the sins of one brief
lifetime
inconceivable it's just not what the
Bible teaches either the Bible says in
the new earth there is no more pain
sorrow death no more crying old things
are passed away all things are made new
so please take a look at that Tom if you
get a chance it's called the rich man
and Lazarus anybody out there if you'd
like to study the subject and understand
it better go there line is open and want
to thank you for your call Tom gonna
talk next to Jerry we've got about two
minutes before the break Jerry you're on
the air
what does the Bible say about people
that refuse to pay money back
well it's you want to just
restrict that to people maybe who had
stolen money from an estate but if
someone steals
whenever a person steals it's a sin you
know don't bear false witness now if a
person is can Vick today have been
stealing and they're convicted by the
Holy Spirit I shouldn't have done that
as far as possible they need to right
the wrongs they can the Book of Ezekiel
talks about that if the sinner repents
of his way in turns and restores the
pledge and if you are a pagan and
you borrow your neighbors lawnmower or
weed eater and you just never return it
after you come to the Lord you can't
just say Lord forgive me for stealing my
neighbor's shovel you need to take the
shovel back and so you know Bible says
we're gonna give an account to God for
every idle word that we spoken and so
we're gonna be giving an account for
every unfaithful thing that we've done
if we walk away from the cash register
and we take more change than we're doing
we don't turn around go back and say hey
look I'm a Christian and you gave me a
little too much here it is God will
always bless us for our honesty now I
used to be a thief before I was a
Christian and I broke into houses and
stole at night and I mean I was doing
burglary stealing cars and there's no
way I can go back and pay that back I
don't even know who the people are I
could never find them again and so in
cases like that where you can't turn
around and write those wrongs you just
have to say lord please forgive me but
in the cases where we can right the
wrongs that we've done to another
through apology or through recompense
you know that's part of what it means to
be converted is try to set things right
now friends you might be hearing thank
you very much for your question Jerry
and you would enjoy our study guide
dealing with the law of God if you want
that call 883 five six seven four seven
I've got a whole sermon on stealing and
that commandment at the amazing facts
website amazing facts 0rg coming back
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation
with powerful reenactments and
incredible visual effects this 95 minute
masterpiece brings to life the book of
Revelation like never before revelation
is no longer a mystery get your copy
today
visit iTunes or AF bookstore calm
in six days God created the heavens and
the earth for thousands of years man has
worshiped God on the seventh day of the
week now each week millions of people
worship on the first day what happened
why did Todd create a day of rest does
it really matter what day we worship who
is behind this great shift discover the
truth behind God's law and how it was
changed visit Sabbath truth calm
can't get enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vor G
[Music]
every Bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live
we still have a few phone lines open if
you have a Bible related question call
us at
1-800-805-3030
for more Bible answers live
welcome back listening friends this is
Bible answers live and as you can tell
it's a live program we do have phones
open if you'd like to call in with your
Bible question the number to the studio
is 800 god says eight hundred four six
three seven two ninety seven I am Doug
Batchelor Pastor John Ross is on
vacation tonight but with the help of
our studio team we're gonna do our best
to man the phones and let's see we don't
want to waste any more time we're gonna
go right back to the phones and
D is next d calling from sacramento
california you're on the air with Bible
answers live yeah hi Pastor Dan hi
yeah sure loud and clear okay good I am
calling because I have been reading in
Matthew I'm just gonna give you the
scriptures and ask that question real
quick
matthew 24:9 to 13 and then 22 23 and
then revelation 13 verse 15 17 it talks
about the last days and the time of
trouble and what will happen to God's
people and based on those Scriptures I'm
not seeing how God will actually take
care of us so I'm wondering if you can
point me to some scripture references
that show that God will provide for
his people during the last days in the
time of trouble well I said he'll take
care of us because it looks to me when I
read that that's not going to happen
well you know I I need to give you a
balance to answer on this
there is a time in the future when Jesus
said there is a great time of trouble
such as there never has been quiet
Christ is actually quoting from Daniel
chapter 12 when it says at that time
Michael will stand up this is verse 1
the Great Prince that stands for the
children of thy people and there will be
a time of trouble such as there never
has been since there was a nation even
unto the same time and then Christ
repeats that in Matthew chapter 24 that
there is a time of great trouble that
doesn't mean that he doesn't protect his
people he's not going to allow his
people to be annihilated but I've got to
be careful not to say that Christians
don't ever suffer there are Christians
suffering in the world today in the
Middle East and North Africa there's
still terrible persecution and some are
losing their lives for their faith I
don't think we need to worry because
Christ says be anxious for nothing
he doesn't want us to fear and
but during the greatest time of trouble
time of trouble seems to be divided in
two parts first there's gonna make a law
you can't buy or sell and then
ultimately there'll be a death decree
when the plagues begin to fall God is
going to then supernaturally protect all
of his people and you find that when the
children of Israel were in Egypt they
were in Egypt but even when the plagues
were falling ten plagues fell they were
preserved during the time of the place
and delivered out of it we will be
preserved in the last days when the
great time of trouble comes and
delivered out of it and just as he
preserved Noah through the flood and he
preserved Daniel in the lion's den and
Shadrach Meshach and Abednego in the
fiery furnace he's going to preserve his
people in the last days and so you don't
need to live in fear
Paul says all that live godly will
suffer persecution and that's not just
true of the last days but from the time
when Abel killed his brother back in the
Garden of Eden all the way through
history believers have experienced
varying forms of trials and persecution
job hijab suffered terribly but it
didn't last long God blessed him 99% of
his life and there was that 1% where for
several weeks and maybe a month he
suffered terribly
so don't despair or don't be concerned D
that about the time of trouble hit are
you worried about it
alright well let me tell you Jesus said
fear not matter of fact white moody went
through the Bible once and he counted
all the time so God said don't be afraid
and I've not done it to check but I
believe him he said there's 365 fear
nuts in the Bible that's one for every
day of the year
Bible said perfect peace God is offering
us great peace have they that love thy
law
nothing will offend him jesus said
peace be still I mean so there's so much
in the Bible where God is saying don't
worry fret not and he doesn't want you
to fear even in Psalm 91 when it talks
about the time of trouble or the plagues
it says a thousand may fall at your side
ten thousand at your right hand but it
will not come near you only with your
eyes will you see and behold the
destruction of the wicked so don't be
afraid D I do have a book on the second
coming I'll send you it's talking about
the tribulation as well as the second
coming and I think you'll find some
comfort there call 883 five six seven
four seven ask for the book called
anything but secret anything but secret
it's explaining that when the Lord comes
it will not be a secret and we'll send
that to you for free thank you for your
call Dee and with that we're gonna be
talking next to Jason who's calling from
Albuquerque New Mexico
welcome Jason you're on the air
yeah I you know Jason I can barely hear
you I don't know if there's anything you
can do to get closer to your phone or
maybe you're on speaker that better that
is better okay
I'm a firm believer is it
all right what does the Bible say about
it talks about women speaking you know
Paul says I suffer not a woman to speak
or to teach and does that mean a woman
should never speak or teach you in a
church first of all I think we all know
that God has inspired both men and women
in ministry to
teach to do various forms of ministry
the place where I see the Bible making a
clear line of distinction is it's clear
to me from the old in the New Testament
that men were called to be the servant
leaders in their family they were to be
the protectors and
it's not as common today because we live
in such a technological age but you know
for the other five thousand nine hundred
years of human history people often
lived in an agricultural society and the
the advantage of the strength of men
they were dependent upon for helping to
sustain the supply protect provide for
their families and they were to be the
spiritual leaders so you do find
examples of women in the Bible teaching
and preaching the word Bible says that
he'll pour out his spirit on men and
women at Pentecost and the Old Testament
men and women served in the capacity of
Prophet Miriam was a prophetess you have
Holda and others where you don't see any
change is only the men served in the
capacity of priests pastor apostle in
the Bible and so I I don't see a woman
ever being ordained as a king by God he
only had the men offer sacrifice only
the men served as priests apostles
pastors so I think that as men are to be
the priests leaders in the family men
were to be the priests leaders in the
church because the church is really a
collection of families it's an extension
of that same principle so does that make
sense daisen can you still hear me
okay well you know I have a book I wrote
on that because we get that question
frequently and it's called women in
ministry I think everyone will find that
it's balanced and biblical women in
ministry call that resource number it's
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven if you have a Bible question
call us at
843-577-5530
madhva tension to people who are like a
black hole they they want lots of time
and attention but they really are never
going to give their heart to Jesus they
just like the tenshun you are casting
your pearls before swine I know it's it
sounds terrible to ever say you would
put anybody in that category and it even
makes me feel bad to say it but Jesus is
clearly talking about
when he was talking to the scribes and
the Pharisees they kept asking questions
not because they wanted to know the
truth but most of them were asking
questions to try to trick him and he
said you know you spend a lot of time
arguing with people that don't have an
appreciation for the truth they're just
arguing cuz I want a debate you are
giving that which is holy to the dogs
you're casting your pigs before your
pearls before those who want to remain
unclean and so Christ was saying don't
waste your time with people to just want
to argue in debate or they don't want to
follow God and they're just soaking up
your time
give your time time is precious give you
time to people that are really hungry
put your seed in soil that is gonna grow
don't cast it on the thorny ground or on
the stones does that make sense rose
absolutely does and I almost had it half
right
you probably were closer than you think
I think so and I appreciate it thank you
all right hey thanks so much appreciate
your call and with that we're gonna talk
next to Robert who's calling from
college place Washington thank you for
your patience Robert you're on the air
yes I was calling to ask you I
understand that the law of God and Moses
are different
but I was wondering about melikhaya for
for that kind of poses a question to me
where it says members while Moses my
servant whom I which I commanded him in
Horeb for all Israel it sounding like
the law of Moses is the Ten Commandments
there well it certainly includes that
but when he says the law of Moses you
know he gave the law of Moses he gave
the law the Ten Commandments to Moses
but if you read there in Exodus that
says God spoke all these words saying
God wrote the commandments of the Ten
Commandments with his own hand Moses
didn't think up or dream up any of the
law all the law that Moses wrote was
inspired now there were different
categories of law there were civil laws
he gave them because they were a new
nation they needed civil laws and
judicial laws much of the judicial law
in America is based on the principles of
what we call the Mosaic law but you know
the law of Moses came from God you've
got health laws these are practical
sanitation laws and and even dietary
restriction laws that are still good
today
there were certain laws that were meant
for a theocracy when God was among the
people you know we obviously don't stone
someone now for adultery and you don't
you know some of the you know we don't
pluck out a person's eye if they poke
out someone else's eye and so when they
lived under a theocracy
with God in their presence they had some
pretty strict laws for those violations
so the Ten Commandments of course
written in stone is eternal the health
laws are eternal civil laws are very
practical but you know they're carried
out by the government so you need to go
by that and a lot of the even the church
law comes from the law of Moses about
delegating and spreading out
responsibilities among representatives
that was given by Jethro to Moses and
passed on now I don't know is that
making sense so far
either
but it's saying that remember the law of
Moses remember so it's something like
the Ten Commandments or
Moses like they're the same thing
well you know if you look in Deuteronomy
chapter 4 where it talks about God
giving his covenant the Ten Commandments
that he wrote and then it says in at
that time I gave unto Moses other
statutes and judgments
so God does make a distinction between
the Ten Commandments and some of the
other statutes and judgments because he
gave everything to Moses on Mount Sinai
that's where he communed with him during
that nearly year that they were camped
there so just because it mentions Mount
Sinai doesn't mean that it's all the 10
command but God spoke to ten
commandments with his voice he wrote
them with his finger he wrote them on
different materials so he spoke them
differently wrote him differently wrote
him on something different put it in a
different place it was in the middle of
the arc in the middle of the temple it
was the holiest spot of the nation was
in the Holy of Holies the inner sanctum
of the sanctuary ten commandments the
ceremonial laws and the other laws were
written on paper by the hand of Moses
not spoken by God's voice and they were
put in the pocket on the outside of the
Ark so God made a pretty big distinction
between the the value of these two laws
and in one point Jesus someone says good
master what shall I do that I might have
eternal life and Christ said thou
knowest the commandments he said which
ones Jesus began to recite the ten
commandments so I there's a distinction
there hey Robert I've got a book called
written in stone it's a study guide I'll
send you a free copy eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven you or
anyone listening and you know friends we
do this by faith and amazing facts we
send out these lessons and by the grace
of God people like you listen and say I
just appreciate that program they're
just sending out Bible material and if
you want to send something to keep us
doing it we are grateful but we'll send
that out to you free it's called written
in stone and we appreciate your question
Robert gonna go to another call though
talk to Larry who is calling from Val de
North Carolina Larry you're on the air
with Bible answers live you there yeah
it's validation North Carolina yeah
that's you and
this is comment question I guess and
Daniel six about the wise men the
astrologers about them and their
families being thrown into the Lions Den
yes and you might have mentioned this is
since they in all likelihood are the
ones that made a eunuch out of Daniel
than just an essence destroyed his
posterity and their posterity was
destroyed and I don't hurt anybody
mention that in long long time and I
didn't know where I heard it from and I
don't know if I actually heard it's been
well you know that that is an
interesting I've never thought of that
it is an interesting thought now let me
just add something when Daniel was made
a eunuch he was probably 17 years and
you're right they took away his
posterity that had been foretold by
Isaiah the prophet 2 Hezekiah he said
the king of Babylon will take of your
seed and will make them eunuchs in the
palace and that exactly happened with
Daniel and his friends but Daniel in the
lion's den happens after the Babylonian
Kingdom fell to the Persians and so
nearly 70 years have gone by Daniels
like 87 years old and
so when their posterity is taken away he
probably had outlived most of the people
that made him eunuchs and but it still
it's an interesting symbol that at the
beginning of the book of Daniel they
take away his posterity but near the end
of the Book of Daniel the King's
advisors lose their posterity
I've never thought of that before
appreciate that insight Dan a Larry god
bless
going next talk to Christian
listening from ann arbor michigan
christian you're on the air with Bible
answers live
thank you for taking my call yeah um
okay so I kind of have a two-part
question because I need to make sure my
understanding is correct before I can
ask my question I read when when Satan
would took Jesus up on the mountain and
offered him essentially the world if he
would bow down to him we showed him all
the kingdoms right and I read that that
the Satan is the Prince of the power of
the air the God the lowercase D god of
this earth right and that we wrestle not
against flesh and blood but against
principalities so
it is Satan's work in this world does he
have that power that he offered Jesus
does does he have that power to give to
men that does say and like produce
himself to men and offer men you know
treasures hang on
right for power and and and wealth and
stuff and did the reason I ask this is
because I I noticed a lot
did I lose you still there
was I cut now cut out for just a second
you said I notice a lot and then go
ahead when I go to movies and and just
in media and stuff I hear a lot and I
see a lot of
Bible stuff just taken in such an evil
way and movies that shouldn't be in like
like Marvel movies and even some
animated movies and most people don't
even notice it you know there's because
I mean there's a lot of people don't
really study their Bible and just you
know the mass mass people but I see so
much evil inside movies like I'll go and
watch x-men and it's just like a
Marvel movie but it's filled with such I
mean like they're they're often making
fun of the scriptures and biblical
principles right right but it's it's
said in such a way that you most people
don't even pick up on it Lee so are you
wondering it are you wondering if Satan
is somehow people have sold their souls
to him in exchange for them being his
agents or is that kind of what you're
thinking
well I'm asking is that true is there
that is there like an evil power at work
in in in like people absolutely in it
yeah absolutely and you know you can see
it very vividly in the media it's it's
you know it doesn't mean everybody in
the media does this there's probably
still some good and godly people out
there but most of the media the scoffs
at the Bible they say these evil
innuendos they misquote things they Mock
the teachings of Jesus they'll exalt
almost everything but it's almost like
they're always exalting this darker
power and so yeah I think that
as a practice I don't go to movies you
know you still manage to see enough of
this stuff just even on news commercials
but
yeah there's a lot of evil out there and
people I think some people have maybe
not consciously sold their souls to the
devil but and a lot of folks in the
music industry listen to the lyrics of
their songs and their diabolical so yeah
you're not missing it Christian would
you let me send you a book I've got a
book that talks about I'll send you a
free copy
the origin of evil and it's called did
God create a devil did God create the
devil if you call our resource number
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven we'll be happy to send you a
free copy of that appreciate that then
we're gonna talk next to a Christopher
who's calling from Bronx New York thank
you for waiting Christopher you're on
the air yes I got a verse about that
about the soul being immortal okay
Matthew chapter 10 verse 28
yeah where it says fear not them that
destroy the body but they can't destroy
the soul rather fear him who can destroy
soul and body
kill the body I mean from the King James
Version but not able to kill the soul
yeah well that means a person you Jesus
said don't be afraid of him who can kill
your body but he can't kill your soul
and I agree with that I think that
there's all kinds of people out there
that might torture a believer but they
can't take away their salvation can they
but the soul is sold what about the soul
of a wicked person
but notice what Jesus says your your
verse actually agrees with me the second
part of it says fear him that's God who
is able to destroy soul and body in hell
so what happens to the soul in hell
well I'm just wondering I'm asking you
to help me out with this verse here when
it says fear him that's God right who is
able to destroy soul and body in hell
right the Bible says in Ezekiel eight
you mean annihilation it's not
so do you believe that people burn
through endless ages for the sins of one
lifetime
God is eternal the Cintas center that
against God so God God is in this and
when you sin against God your sin is
because
infinite
so it destroys just one sin the Bible
says that whatsoever to keep the whole
law and offend at one point he's guilty
of all so the 13 year old alright just
stay with me here the 13 year old
Aborigine in Australia I've been out
there in the outback and worked with the
some of the original Aborigines 13 year
old boy he dies
from a suicide
and you believe that he will burn a
million years ago by constant fire a
billion years ago by constant fire for
the sins of 13 years and he was made by
God he never learned about Jesus and
that if the Bible says Christ said I'm
gonna reward everyone according to what
he deserves and there are varying
rewards jesus said he that knew his
master's will and didn't do it he's
beaten with many stripes he that did not
know is beaten with few there are
varying degrees of rewards so I find
that the Bible says that the penalty for
sin is death and
the everlasting punishment that it talks
about in the Bible means the punishment
the sentence is eternal there is no
second chance it is a second death there
is no relief it will last forever they
are gone forever it doesn't mean they
burn forever and ever and ever I mean
just that is the creepiest thing in the
world it used to make me hate God before
I learned what the Bible really said
in all your life
wait a second now Jesus died to save us
from perishing right he said so
you and I agree that praise the Lord
he's giving sinners a chance to live and
not die and I don't even want to go to
the lake of fire and suffer however long
it see we believe there's a lake of fire
but it's not going to burn forever and
ever people are cast in the lake of fire
revelation 20 this is the second death
and the Bible says all the wicked will
be consumed it will leave them neither
root nor branch that's Malachi chapter 4
please if this makes any sense to you at
all Christopher don't go with what
people have been telling you all your
life
did for yourself lots of verses I'll
send you a study guide is the devil in
charge of hell is the devil in charge of
hell anyone out there if you want to
understand this subject better and you
know people sail past it ugh you don't
believe in hell yes I do actually my
hell is hotter than some people tell
because my hell burns them up the Bible
says they will be burnt up they will be
consumed it says they'll be devoured
never will thou be any more I mean the
language is so clear there's a few
verses that are difficult but the the
whole scale seems to get tipped in favor
of a few difficult verses and they
ignore all the other verses that make it
very clear two choices life and death
believe live do not believe perish all
right friends we are out of time and by
the way that book is called is the devil
in charge of Hell the phone number 808
three five six seven four seven and
please keep us on the air during
Thanksgiving I hope you're thankful for
this program you've heard us ask I'd
love to have you go to the phone do
something or go to the Internet amazing
facts dot o-r-g and click donate god
bless you appreciate those who call in
didn't get your call we'll do it again
next week thank you
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
life's a curious thing I mean just when
things seem under control wham you're
hit with something new your marriage is
good suddenly it's on the brink of
divorce
the jobs great and then it's gone and so
is your life savings
you feel healthy Danny a doctor gives
the bad news what's coming next you
could look to the stars but they don't
have the answers but this does the
prophecy Study Bible by amazing facts
this Bible special its 27 personal study
guides lead you on a life-changing
journey through God's Word to discover
real answers to life's questions from
health and relationships to family and
the future the hopes in here get your
amazing facts prophecy Study Bible today
by calling
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word visit our website at
WWF ag0 RG and sign up for our free
Bible study course and make sure to
check out our online bookstore at AF
bookstore com which offers thousands of
inspiring books DVDs and more to help
you get the most out of God's Word to
take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast call us at
$887
RG did you enjoy this program make sure
to tell your family and friends tune in
next time for more Bible answers live
honest and accurate answers to your
Bible questions
[Music]